bonjour à tous mais
tradition des espaces autochtone en
direct on se demandait où on était
rendus on est là on est bien là pour ce
vendredi de pâques
aujourd'hui on va parler des enfants en
fait on va parler de protection des
enfants chez les attikameks parce qu'il
ya eu beaucoup de changements au cours
des derniers mois au cours des dernières
semaines qui implique donc les les
communautés j'allais dire les trois
communauté attikamek au québec mais ce
n'est pas le cas donc on va préciser
tout ça avec nos invités
un premier tour de table je vous
présente constant awashish grand chef de
la nation atikamekw
bonjour bienvenue dans nos studios mais
refuse isabelle picard wendat de wend
hacker bonjour bonjour pour notre
chronique habituel puisque vous êtes
avec nous ils appellent toutes les
semaines
et puis marie laure josselin qui est
journaliste à radio canada marie marie
laure qui a travaillé
bonjour marie laure qui a travaillé
pendant j'allais dire plusieurs mois
presque un an
ouais sur ce dossier là ce dossier du
système de protection de l'enfance chez
les attikameks un système de protection
de l'enfance qui était en préparation
depuis très longtemps l'alluré même qui
était en fête qui a commencé au début
des années 2000 qui s'est mis en place
tranquille tranquillement ça s'appelle
le système d'intervention d'autorité
attikameks donc il y avait toujours
québec
la dpj qui étaient là mais
tranquillement les on va dire que si la
manière de faire louis s'est développée
a changé au début était quand même très
très calqué sur ce que faisait la dpj et
puis tranquillement pas vite ils ont
adopté adaptées aussi pour refléter plus
la culture attikameks il y à un peu plus
d'un an et ils sont devenus autonomes
puis à 5 mois québec est complètement
sortir et c'est le conseil de la nation
nos coeurs avec le grand chef qui
s'occupe totalement avec la protection
sociale des enfants de manawan wemotaci
et la tuque
voilà on va préciser tout de suite on en
parle aujourd'hui parce que vous avez
préparé un papier là dessus un reportage
donc pour le web et un reportage pour la
radio également il fait qui sera
diffusée dimanche j'ai effectivement
parce qu'en quand on l'a appris c'est
sorti officiellement mais concrètement
sur le terrain comment ça se passe et
comment ça se traduise et autres de dire
ya un conseil de famille un cercle des
dents on voit les gens ressentent et
puis comment juste cette manière de
faire des fois c'est juste se réunir
d'aller chercher un grand-père des
choses qui paraissent parfois simples
comment ça ça fonctionne pour la
communauté oui alors grand chef awashish
il y a vingt ans ce n'est pas vous qui
étiez sur le dossier mais vous l'avez vu
évoluer au fil du temps qui lui évolue
et je n'ai entendu pas roulé j'ai été
plus sage est bannie plots d'un depuis
ma première élection en 2014
pour vous c'est devenu une priorité
il fallait que ça fonctionne ouais mais
je pense est évident et à tout moment
pas de se faisait longtemps
on a travaillé très fort beaucoup c'est
justement les gouvernements à agir dans
ce sens et
je pense que c'était beaucoup de travail
mais il y avait déjà eu beaucoup de
travail de faire ça juste de klose et ce
au stade aussi le sait ce qu on sait ce
qu'on a fait dans les annales d'accord
donc le travail était très très avancées
mais comme taylor l'a dit tantôt on a
commencé notre travail des années 2000
ordu mais on a commencé à mettre notre
système en place on a commencé jeudi se
passent de cette manière la c1
on a commencé à approuver faire la
preuve que le système fonctionne très
bien et tranquillement les choses se
sont se sont mises en place
tranquillement je pense l'examen ont été
encouragés par notre appui donc pu
obtenir ce qu'on a obtenu dernière on va
juste préciser une chose je le disais
nourriture ce sont les autres les
communauté attikamek mais pas toutes
pourquoi toute votre communauté
d'origine obedjiwan n'aurait pas partie
malheureusement il n'en font pas partie
si mais c'est une décision qui est
passée qu'à l'époque je pensais en 2003
il ya eu la patrie mais de servir la
communauté d'obedjiwan pour plusieurs
raisons j'ignore totalement mais ce que
je sais c'est vraiment c'est vrai on m'a
pas aidé c'est qu'on m'a parlé des
gamins d'éloignement yama vos questions
de coûts est question le temps d'un
éclair comme nos têtes un peu éloigné
mais je pensais beaucoup d'intérêt la
part de la communauté d'obedjiwan mais
non polluants posent suisse
l'ado aussi depuis 2003 alors donc
parlons de ce système d'intervention
d'autorité attikameks parce que c'est
son nom officiel
comment ils fonctionnent comme elle
fonctionne mature vous il ya toujours
une plante on peut rêver il ya des gens
qui il ya des enfants qui sont dans des
situations compromettantes ou à des
situations où ce que ou annoncé des
pères la famille qui sont un peu sur la
difficulté sont dans une période
difficile
le système notamment à son bon premier
malade à la protection de la jeunesse a
dit jamais composé dernier oui oui
intervient effet une approche face à la
famille et francis otc
le stand est troisième c'est vraiment de
travailler avec la famille il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sort d'une
nouvelle ère ce propos la vie ce qui est
ce que les gens disent en eau comme
dorothée est ce que les gens disent ah
non dans notre organisation sur la main
la preuve qui est différent c'est
vraiment la proche
face à la famille c'est de faire
contribuer les familles à la résolution
du problème à la protection de l'enfant
de leurs enfin sous vaz et si ça peut
être une chicane de couple qui crée une
situation explosive qui kim et qui crée
un environnement qui peut décemment
saint pons enfants qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour remédier à cette situation le mans
ont fait participer la famille ont fait
participer des divers pour justement
qu'ils puissent dialoguer puisse prendre
conscience de dodge de la situation qui
puisse prendre conscience également que
le comportement peut nuire à leur enfant
qu'elle a enfin été affectés par cette
situation le je pensais vraiment c'est
de parler c'est pour moi ce que c'est
c'est naturel je pense surtout les
autochtones a généré assez naturel et
gamin c'est
l'important c'est de communiquer c'est
de parler de se comprendre et superbe
dans la vie aujourd'hui dans la vie de
tous les jours on prend pas le temps de
dialoguer je pense les gens sont là mais
ce coton doux et je suis le problème
rapidement est important de comprendre
les situations et de stoney trail ancien
mec c'est vraiment sûr c'est vraiment de
2,2 de parler de dialogue et de résoudre
le problème
ensemble les demandes conscience
ensemble oui marie laure vous l'avez
vécu sur place parce que vous êtes allez
justement rencontré des familles des
familles qui se sont confiés à vous en
plus ils ont révélé une partie de leur
vie qui vous ont expliqué pourquoi ils
en sont arrivés là
oui puis l'arrêt justement demandé à la
famille pourquoi elle avait décidé de
venir parler parce que venir parler de
ces problèmes parce que c'est pas obligé
c'est pas un homme mais moyenne est
obligé de me parler mais dont qu'ils ont
ils sont finalement venus et puis sont
vraiment parler sans tabou parce que
justement quand je leur ai demandé
pourquoi et m'ont répondu parce qu'il
croyait justement ce système est qu'il
trouvait importante de pouvoir le
vulgariser on va dire est que d'autres
communautés s'en sert comme exemple la
femme était in ou et touré nous la
famille nous le monsieur étatique un mec
est pour eux c'est important de dire
justement qu'ils ont trouvé une façon de
faire qui visiblement de ce que j'ai
ressenti c'est quelque chose qui est
traditionnel qui est ancestrale mais
mais qu'on a un petit peu oublié qu'on
oublie de réutiliser de manière
naturelle
la première étape c'est le cercle de
famille donc j'ai pas pu assister un
cercle de famille parce que même la
directrice des pros de la protection
sociale n'y a pas le droit c'est très
restreint mais eux me l'ont raconté la
personne qu'ils organisent donc ça se
fait ça ne se fait pas dans les bureaux
de la protection sociale c'est important
que ça se passe en dehors donc ça peut
être dans la salle des archives où il ya
de l'artisanat en écosse où il ya quand
même un sentiment de se sentir bien où
ça peut se faire aussi dans d'autres
endroits dans le bourg
et l'hiver peut-être pas mais et et le
cercle de famille donc ils se mettent en
rond et il ya un prix à une petite
bougie au milieu une prière
remerciements aux créateurs enfin bref
la personne fait comme elle le veut à ce
moment là pour pouvoir donner du courage
et là sans dire qu'est ce que tu as fait
pourquoi t'as fait ça c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe et on va attendre la
première personne qui va parler va
parler où on va guider dans les paroles
il ya la famille proche si les enfants
sont en âge d'y participer y participent
et puis vraiment quand on dit la famille
proche chez les grands parents qui
peuvent être là ça se passe chez les
attikameks là je pense c'est 96% des
attikameks qui parle leur langue en
premier quand ils se croisent au mcdo à
la tuque
il parle on attikameks donc il ya
vraiment une importance de parler dans
leur langue et comme ça se passe dans la
langue la famille m'indique déjà c'est
ça qui était grandiose de pouvoir se
dire les choses dvd c'est un ancien
policier qui a vu beaucoup de choses
dans les communautés beaucoup de
suicides qui a été beaucoup qui a enlevé
pour l'enlever qui a pris pour la dpj
des enfants et c'était quelque chose une
douleur qui n'arrivait pas à partager
et là il a pu la partager que sa femme
sa belle mère d'autres personnes dans sa
langue et la cité en attique à maquiller
nous donc ces thèmes et l'intervenante
permettait de parler les deux langues et
deux le pouvoir parler comme ça même
s'il parlait très bien français c'était
différent parce que il exprime l émotion
exactement avec le bon nous et pour eux
ça c'est ce qui faisait la différence de
pouvoir vraiment dire ce qu'ils
voulaient donc bon terme sans jugement
sans sens voilà sans jugement sans point
montré du doigt la personne c'est
vraiment être à l'écouté puis la
personne dans dans cette première
instance fait partie de la solution
c'est ok tu as dis ça tu as peut-être
renoue peut-être ta mère a eu un impact
sur ce que tu es devenu et peut-être
qu'elle aussi elle veut parler et puis à
partir de là on va essayer de trouver
une solution ensemble
et s'il ya besoin de cette aide on va
aller chercher un cercle des dents
autour c'est comme l'année de la main
mais en tout cas déjà pour la langue je
pense vous pouvez parler sur
l'importance de parler de le dire non à
wade
oui oui allez-y comme ça je pensais
vous avez tout à fait raison là dessus
même moins l'occasion mais un peu tout
en ville j'étais entouré de francophones
mais à la base quand j'étais plus jeune
j'étais j'étais départ milliards ben le
côté émotionnel on dirait que les mots
7h mieux que cette année il fera frais
quand je parle le français blessés doit
être trouvé mais mes émotions en
français mais c'est quand même très laid
[Musique]
et les émotions viennent se mêler aussi
à ça à notre langue d'origine c'est
notre langue qui accueille toutes nos
émotions aux six ans et celle qui nous
permet de nous exprimer
je pense le plus facilement tout à fait
maintenant le fait un show pour un sac
de partir en français
les émotions serait pas pareil à l'appel
malheureusement après des cinémas gamme
est encore vivant mais quand j'exprime
est des choses qui m'affecte et des
bagages tombent et fascinant oui moi
c'est comme ça dans le sang ce maquis
qui m'a dit oui alors si on réussit pas
donc à cette première étape au niveau du
cercle ce même bien réussi parce qu'on
est même pas rendus là c'est qu'ils
réussirent sept mois hier étape on peut
on peut prendre un cercle des dents donc
admettons vous êtes ma meilleure amie
donc on va les prendre sans forcément
expliqué que la situation dans les
détails de dire peut-être si j'ai besoin
d'une thérapie pic marne le mardi matin
c'est ma thérapie puis vont croiser
tiens t'es pas la thérapie on va y aller
ensemble c'est vraiment c'est des
béquilles
oui je l'appelle à 50 ans des béquilles
qui bat pour s'appuyer ou quelque chose
qui banbanaste qui balisent le chemin
pour essayer d'aller de l'avant je
réellement et donc ça peut être les
grands parents il dans le cercle donc ça
peut être vraiment des amis le
professeur cissé donne pour des enfants
qui ont des besoins
c'est vraiment ça le cercle des dents
évidemment les aidants doivent eux ne
pas avoir de problématique parce que
sinon on ne peut pas s'appuyer sûr aussi
c'est difficile pour eux aussi mais et
les dents parfois aussi ça peut être bon
mais moi ça va pas en ce moment je peux
pas je peux pas régler mon problème on
va dire j'ai mes enfants parce que la
majorité en plus de 50% plus de la
moitié c'est des cas de négligence il
faut quand même le dire c'est plus de la
moitié pour des cas de négligence donc
je vais pas bien donc je néglige
devenant le fan mont noir
je voyais manquent pas comme il faut de
mon enfant donc peut-être que ma mère
elle va dire le temps que tu as et mieux
je vais aller m'occuper ton enfant le
temps de répit après la grand mère que
j'ai j'ai que j'ai rencontré trouvé ça
difficile cette position d'être
d'autorité d'être la grand mère mais qui
est la mère aussi pendant plusieurs mois
ou plusieurs années le temps que
l'enfant
donc c'était quelque chose qui pour elle
était pesant même si alizée mais pour
rien au monde je changerais parce que
sinon probablement la dpj à windham
parce qu'il y avait quand même à ce
moment là encore la dpj qui était oui
oui oui l'année au-dessus des têtes donc
c'est vraiment indécis des aidants mais
voilà des aidants depuis là encore je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui a
toujours existé grand chef awashish
votre grand mère a été votre aidantes
quand on voit ça parce que vous avez été
levée par votre grand mère
ouais on pourrait vu les ventes de sa
maman oui et encore oui mon grand père
surtout mon grand père j'ai été très
proche de mon appel un appel très jeune
j'étais toujours dans la région surtout
que les viandes aux pauvres ou camille
claud voix s'élèvent anciens villages
progresse si on est toujours dans cette
région le on se promenait un bateau
avant d'aller rendre visite aux hôtes
est né à alep acquis que kuppel
territoire c'est ce que le monsieur r
j'étais jeune mais je t'ai toujours très
bien mon grand bac je voulais toujours
le suivant fois je me suis qui je ne
peux pas avec moi peut-être fatigué je
m'en réjouis
c'est puis - d'où cette envie je voulais
pourrait ne pas être le seul sans lui
oui je n'ai jamais jamais jamais le ma
mère a way vient te font partie de la
journée mais il y avait raison un 14-0
d'après-midi le jeu comme en fait ce qui
était mais j'avais faim je n'avais pas
le choix de suivre
oui c'est moi y avait choisi d'aller
ouais ouais c'est eux qui vous ont ils
vu exactement donc c'était les et dans
l'eure le cercle des aidants là si on
repart dans le système après le cercle
des aidants ya d'autres états on va
devenir donc ça a été chiffré un jeu
quand même pour que québec se retire il
a fallu avoir des chiffres
oui ils prouvaient que ça fonctionnait
oui oui donc 90% des autres les dossiers
sont résolus en conseil de famille avec
le cercle des dents donc après on n'est
pas encore à l'étape de la
judiciarisation évidemment non pas des
cas lourds qui empruntent la voie de la
judiciarisation aussitôt là mais oui si
la famille si la personne ne veut pas
s'il ne respecte pas ce qui a été décidé
en conseil de famille il ya la
judiciarisation avant ça le conseil des
sages c'est le donc là ce sont douze
dix personnes cinq hommes cinq femmes
parité qui sont élus par les conseils de
manawan et de wemotaci là la différence
ce sont eux qui vont on va dire imposer
une solution aux parents ou aux enfants
mais ça c'est là encore ça se fait de
manière on discute on écoute on va te
guider plus que on va encore de te dire
que question de juger c'est ça il n'y a
pas de jugement donc et mais après si ça
marche pas bons mais ils le savent c'est
la judiciarisation puis là ça arrive ça
c'est vrai et puis avec ce système
depuis le début du système donc presque
20 ans et 80 % de moins de 4
judiciarisation c'est quand même
beaucoup ça fait ça c'est qu'ils
allaient ready faire moi qui avais aussi
que le système carcéral il ya beaucoup
d'autochtones qui sont dedans et puis
que justement il voulait essayer de
changer ça donc
l'impression que c'est quand même
gagnant gagnant le système fonctionne
québec
oui on est parent isolé kullman station
la vitesse oui oui alors ce système là
il va pouvoir s'arrimer au projet de loi
c 92 qui est en préparation au niveau du
gouvernement fédéral est en première
lecture il a béni oui oui tout à fait
mais avant de parler de ça j'ai envie de
parler de nos élites ou d'un code
judiciaire important dans s'inscrit dans
le cadre du sujet dont on parle
aujourd'hui c'est cindy blackstock que
vous connaissez peut-être qui est
directrice générale de la société de
soutien à l'enfance et à la famille des
premières nations qui en 2007 appuyé par
l'assemblée des premières nations au
niveau à fédéral a déposé une plainte
contre le gouvernement et canadiens
devant la commission canadienne des
droits de la personne
la plainte alléguait que les services
sociaux offerts par le gouvernement
fédéral aux enfants autochtones dans les
réserves plus précisément et
indirectement l'on parle de financements
longs vision et ont donc été inférieure
à aux services offerts aux enfants
canadiens donc aux enfants allochtone
par les gouvernements provinciaux entre
autres et ce même si les besoins des
enfants autochtones étaient criants oui
et là j'ai fait une petite pause pour
vous rappeler une statistique 50 2
points 2 % des enfants au canada qui se
retrouvent en famille d'accueil sont des
enfants autochtones donc un enfant sur
deux alors qu'ils ne représentent que 7
points 7 rangs de la population des
enfants canadiens
c'est de ça alors qu'ils puissent
adopter gym qui va guider dit oui donc
la plainte est déposée en 2007 les
auditions vont tarder la première
audition va avoir lieu en 2014 et madame
blackstock attribue ce délai au
gouvernement fédéral qui selon elle
aurait multiplié les procédures afin de
faire tomber l'atteindre d'ailleurs le
gouvernement canadien a dépensé et 5.3
millions $ en frais juridiques avant
même la tenue de la première audience en
octobre 2004 alors ton qu'à l'époque on
le rappelle c'était le gouvernement
conservateur qui était 8 fois oui tout à
fait quelle est la décision le tribunal
des droits de la personne statut que le
modèle de services sociaux offerts par
le gouvernement canadien aux enfants
autochtones des premières nations en
fait se traduit par une absence de
service
créer une variété de conséquences
négatives pour les enfants et les
familles qui vivent sur les réserves
la décision stipule aussi que le
gouvernement doit cesser cette pratique
discriminatoire et prendre les mesures
afin de corriger et surtout de prévenir
ce genre de situation est donc une telle
décision a sans doute eu un impact
important sur ce qui suit et là je parle
du projet de loi
c92 l'heure donc évidemment ce projet-là
s'inscrit dans la sur représentation des
enfants des premières nations dont on
parlait tant dans les zéniths aussi les
médecins c'est la même chose on a même
parlé d'une crise humanitaire à un
moment donné et des organisations des
premières nations et des organisations
même allochtone des leaders qui pendant
longtemps pendant plusieurs années se
sont levés et ont dû batailler tant que
ces choses là mais elle est là pour dire
regardez les choses on est trop loin
finalement il faut ramener sait
absolument pas ce que la proche des
services à l'enfance et à la famille
autochtone consistait tout doucement à
séparer les enfants de leurs familles et
de leur collectivité et donc de leur
culture oui donc ce qu'il faut savoir
aussi c'est que le projet de loi c 92
s'inscrit aussi dans la ratification par
le gouvernement canadien de la
convention des nations unies relative
aux droits de l'enfant oui et aussi de
la déclaration des nations unies sur les
droits des peuples autochtones
oui faut se rappeler aussi que les cinq
premières appel à l'action de la
commission de vérité et réconciliation
touché également la protection à
l'enfance
donc c'est vraiment un appel qui a été
lancée de deux toutes parts et la plaine
de madame blackstock certainement
contribué à ce projet de loi donc le
gouvernement canadien élaboré de concert
avec les peuples autochtones avec les
premières nations avec le gouvernement
limite le peuple métis également une
nouvelle loi visant justement à réduire
le nombre d'enfants et de jeunes
autochtones qui vont être pris en charge
et aussi à améliorer les services à
l'enfance et à la famille dans les
communautés à l'automne 2010 8 nuits à
un groupe qui a été créée formé du
gouvernement canadien et des trois
groupes dont je viens vous parler et le
28 février dernier la loi concernant les
enfants les jeunes et les familles des
premières nations des inuits et des
métis ont été déposés au parlement une
en première lecture
donc c'est un projet de loi qui vise à
affirmer le droit des gouvernements des
premières nations des inuits et des
métis d'exercer
leurs propres compétences sur les
services à l'enfance et à la famille et
c'est un projet de loi qui vise aussi à
établir des principes généraux disons
permettant l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant la continuité culturelle aussi
et il ya une réelle égalité ce qui n'est
pas le cas pour l'instant dans ce convoi
dans l'ariège
donc ce sont des principes qui vont
guider les collectivités autochtones qui
vont guider aussi les provinces et les
territoires parce que souvent la
protection de l'enfance c'est au niveau
fédérer vers provincial la vie et donc
ces sites un projet de loi qui vise à ne
pas séparer les familles et à réduire le
nombre d'enfants autochtones bien sûr
pris en charge en bout de ligne c'est un
projet de loi qui met l'accent sur la
nécessité d'un système d'abord axée sur
la prévention plutôt que sur la prise en
charge ce qui n'était pas le cas jusqu'à
maintenant donc on va accorder la
priorité aux services de prévention dans
les communautés de plus c'est un projet
de loi un projet de loi qui indique
qu'aucun enfant ne devrait être pris en
charge sur la seule base et logistique
ou pas une personne des conditions socio
économiques y compris la pauvreté et le
manque de logements
le problème c'est que chez les
autochtones 38 % des enfants sont dans
une situation de pauvreté exact
comparativement à environ 7% chez les
canadiens oui donc la pauvreté devient
un enjeu qui est carrément systémique et
c'est difficile de se sortir de tout ça
la pauvre texte c'est une course de
place
alors si maintenant on comprend mieux
les choses et qu'on ne se bat plus là
dessus pour placer les enfants des gens
on va faire un grand pas en avant
maintenant le projet de loi cherche à
préserver les liens donc avec la famille
la collectivité et surtout la culture on
sait que la culture a dans le passé
toute l'histoire
bon les pensionnats toutes les coupures
culturelles identitaires ont causé
d'énormes tas aux premières nations aux
premiers peuples et l'on était entré par
un système archaïque de continuer
finalement c'est l'on ne parlait tout à
l'heure de l'importance de dire les
choses dans sa langue
tu disais tout à l'heure que tu t'es
allé sur le territoire avec ton
grand-père donc c'est une manière aussi
à travers quand on reste dans la
collectivité d'apprendre sa culture que
de perpétuer sa et d'être plus fort je
pense que oui collectivités alors à
suivre
ce projet de loi qui en est à sa
première et sa première lecture est ce
qu'il aura le temps de passer avant les
élections d'octobre
n'est ce pas justement dans les dents
les phoques
si un enfant doit être placé le fiat
favorisent la famille d'accueil
attikameks partie les jeunes m'ont dit
qu'ils sont dedans ça m'a vraiment
permis de me retrouver puis c'est drôle
parce que je suis retombé sur un une
famille le jeune je les avais vus au
grand rassemblement de mashteuiatsh il
ya deux ans j'avais des photos justement
du père de kick hier qui est donc enfin
l'enfant est placé dans cette famille
l'aï les deux jouer justement et avec le
fils c'était les mêmes c'est comme ses
deux fils et pour lui c'est ça ça lui a
permis vraiment d'apprendre ça alors que
d'enfants qui sont placés dans des
familles à l'automne un moment ou un
autre ils le disent
sa frappe ils ont besoin d'aller
chercher mais ouais dans les dents les
défis dont vous m'avez parlé constant et
puis aussi alice clairet de la
directrice de la protection sociale
c'est justement la pauvreté le manque de
logements sont les principaux défis puis
après aussi comment gérer si un parent
on n'a pas le droit de s'approcher de
leur forme comment gérer ça dans une
petite communauté ça devient aussi
compliqué
[Musique]
justement parlons-en parce que ces
fameux défi là logement pauvreté
comment est-ce qu'on va être capable de
les surmonter pour que justement le
système fonctionne comme un grand peuple
et sont montés je pense et avec beaucoup
de sensibilisation faisait un bond au
classement général mais également y voir
la main ça peut être très longtemps que
les gens sont au courant que dans nos
communautés on ne manque de logements
comment on peut programmer des jeux
partout augmenter le financement retenu
gaulle
c'est un investissement pour voir ça
comme un coup d'essai dans les logements
dans les communautés mais savoir réduire
les problèmes de faire c'est une des
causes premières de toutes les problèmes
sociaux comme ça va permettre un
meilleur climat la communauté ça va
permettre également donner un meilleur
environnement pour ces jeunes de
persévérer à l'école souvent qu'on y
trouve sur peu plus dans une maison mais
c'est ce n'est pas propice à l'étude
loin de là au contraire à l'effet que ça
les fait qu à tout les niveaux
justaucorps le 26 classes à la fec à
tous les niveaux puis je pense et les
eaux en afrique anciens en investir dans
ces pour c'est vraiment quelque chose de
positif le comment faire financer le
système d'intervention
bah c'est le gouvernement fédéral qui a
100 % à 100 % - et donne suffisamment
d'argent actuellement actuelle
actuellement notre système mais depuis
la signature de l'entente
on ne jetait mais ça a été long terme
oui ça a pris du temps pour ces raisons
le fait toujours
lequel son financement du gouvernement
voulait poste avancé que la feb aux
trolls et les aboutissants les vaut
prendre de chance ou de la lingue force
de parler avec eux de négocier avec eux
de leur présenter système de voir les
avantages de la démontrer les avantages
mais ils auraient embarqué d'un système
de noues est jeune on a suffisamment
d'argent dans le système d'intervention
mais je pense aux autres aux opérations
ça devrait toujours facile par les temps
tous progest 92 kg
c'est un projet de loi qui est très
intéressant qui qui donne à la première
nation le taux nominaux cette matière le
candide l'outil qui dans des lits
principe en ce qui concerne la
protection de la jeunesse un peu partout
cadre nous avait on a quand même une
longueur d'avancé à ce niveau là c'est
avantageux pour nous mais je pensais
bien juste renforcé notre position
instant ni bull maintenant pour d autres
nations mais y'a encore encore il faudra
d'abord à sion desdites des provinces à
tous les niveaux
à projet de loi on voit qu'il faut des
accords de quoi bien sanglé avec les
provinces pour s'assurer que tu peut
s'exercer vraiment le poids qui est
octroyée par le droit fédéral
le projet de loi c 501 fédéral qui donne
le pouvoir de s'occuper de ces jeunes de
chaque communauté a maintenant et la
compétence auprès de vue mais avec le
jeu de l'article 81 lui tout ce que vous
ce que les lois d'application générale
province et à la cantine à celle qu'il
avait du mal comme noté labeouf loi c
soit converser vraiment l' art 88
nouvelle dont se soit vraiment clair
qu'il ya encore libao attend des
déboires à ce que la province doit
accepter que la compétence soit comme un
peu retiré le tir et on parle déjà en
fonction des enjeux et et c'est cette
question qui est ce qui me vient à
l'esprit est ce qu'on y est alité dans
les communautés et cbi loi fédérale de
recettes qui est le quinqua pas de loi
fédérale qui est une compétence qui
tutoyait la première nation mais c'est
la loi du québec qui est ce que ça veut
dire qu'en faisant ce projet à douai le
toutes les lois d'application main à son
automatisme alors le système
d'intervention il est en place chez vous
j'imagine que les autres communautés que
ce soit les innu les wendat est-ce qu'on
vous observe à ce qu'on vous pose des
questions est-ce qu'on est intéressé par
votre façon de faire
oui on était des gens de l'ouest
canadien qui est qu'ils sont intéressés
les émeutes et 90 au québec partout à
travers le parti nous observe t on à 720
comme ça c'est fait ça s'est pas fait du
jour au lendemain
ou c'est ça les arrange on m'installe en
place ça c'est comme ça nous je pense on
été les pionniers on a su le démontrer
mais peu de détails on ne va pas
seulement le matin dont la chanson nul
quand même certaines banques
collaboration du gala provincial
asthénie gaulle où ils ont toujours
donné la chance et on modifie la loi de
en 2000 2001 avec l'insertion de
l'article 37 5 qui donnait la
possibilité justement d'avoir incité
l'équipe qui était une épouse une
rumination parce qu'ils étaient on est
quand même une bonne collaboration juin
provincial si au québec ailleurs je sais
pas jusqu'où je pourrais je connais pas
vraiment l'expérience 1 au pouvoir
puisque gens atteints et l'opération
jardins des contacts un peu partout
l'autre canadien sicile des fois le
laisse son poste réussissent c'est en
quelque sorte qu est ce qui est désolant
dans toute cette chose là on parle d'
injecter plus d'argent mais en même
temps présentement les systèmes sont
pour non seulement très bien accueillis
mais là certains provinces où ce que
l'enfant devient quasiment je prédis
fait partie d'un système qui est qui qui
m'ont atteint on pourrait ville le ciel
depuis que les assigne un peu de tout ce
qu'on lire et imelda c'est l'heure du
crime
c'est désolant
regardez cette question le dos de façon
vraiment attentif à d'ailleurs jugé ce
matin
72% des enfants qui sont placés en
familles d'accueil sont des enfants
autochtones soit 100 douce et enoh et
quelques communautés qui arrive à faire
notamment en colombie britannique mène
guise je pense qu'ils arrivent quand
même à gérer puis depuis dix ans il n'y
a pas un enfant qui est sortie qui a été
placée mais ils sont quand même ils sont
pas autonomes quand même donc mais il
arrive à faire leur système après ces
petits quoi c'est des petites deux
petits exemples
quelles sont les limites parce qu'il
doit y en avoir des limites à ce système
d'intervention attikameks vous m'avez un
grand chef qui est qu'ils la gardent le
système de garde
c'est loin il faudrait vraiment avec des
gens
vive ce au quotidien qui intervient à ce
niveau là les limites mais c'est quand
les gens vont là bas on se ramasse dans
un système qui est qui et notre note qui
est pas notre système on ça devient
judiciariser mais c'est après
l'expérience tard une fois depuis le oui
marie laure vous qu'est-ce que vous avez
constaté sur place
avant d aller c'est sûr je me posais la
question de la promiscuité parce que si
on parle plus que de la négligence mais
la maltraitance et que l'enfant ait
retiré confie chez la grand mère la
grand-mère son propre fils n'a pas droit
d'approcher son petit fils ça peut
devenir tendue dans l'économie parle de
quelques milliers d'habitants donc c'est
sûr que c'est quand même quelque chose
de difficile à gérer
la direction a protection sociale
m'expliquer que justement il nous
expliquait à la personne commence à
fonctionner et puis que s'il fallait il
aller prendre il allait appeler la
police
et puis c'est déjà arrivé et m'a dit on
a déjà dû faire intervenir la police
parce qu'il ya des choses qui ne
respectaient pas mais comme jocelyn le
papa qui s'occupe qui est de famille
d'accueil depuis une vingtaine d'années
lui bah il promet justement toujours
évidemment avec les services sociaux la
proximité avec le parent puis sans le
juger lui-même moi j'avoue j'étais
impressionné par ce qu'il dit moi je
veux j'explique à l'enfant tu peux être
en colère parce que ton parents
s'occupent pas de poids mais ça arrive
c'est un adulte il va se reprendre
papa maman ils vont se reprendre c'est
ce qui m'a dit puis c'était comme moi et
c'est bon pas parler et donc ça permet
de créer ce lien sans que l'enfant soit
dans la rancoeur ou la colère il apprend
sa culture tout ça même si 100 dans
cette famille mais ils se disent à
chaque fois que j'en aurai qui part ça
nous pincent le coeur mais on se dit que
c'est que c'est la personne va mieux
puisque l'enfant il est mieux avec ses
parents donc il sait comme vraiment
chacun aussi avec peut-être sa
philosophie de pensée et son passé puis
de voir que ensemble ils vont réussir à
porter l'enfant pour qu'il s'en sorte
oui après c'est sûr qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de problématiques un jeune qui
est très heureux d'avoir grandi dans le
milieu attikameks a fait beaucoup de
foyers il a été adopté aussi là il est
parti à trois-rivières en centre
jeunesse et il m'a dit moi fou je
m'éloigne de wemotaci parce que sinon je
vais être tentés de retomber dans la
consommation lui il a besoin de
s'éloigner qui sans qui perd sa culture
le bois lui manque
parler
donc il est vraiment dans ce sentiment
double de devoir quitter pour essayer
parce qu'il sent qu'il n'a pas les reins
assez solides mais d'un autre côté ça
lui banques mais il a rencontré un jeune
qui a été adopté par une famille
allochtone qui savait pas du tout qu'il
était attikameks puis là il s'est dit
non ça j'aurais jamais voulu parce que
ce qu'il veut du hamas et réussir pour
revenir redonner à sa communauté donc
c'est un cerf qui a toujours ce lien qui
est très très très fort même s'il est
jeune on a beau dire ils sont derrière
forte n'a été tous d'ailleurs quand même
le lien là qui est là est vraiment très
très très très très fort alors on disait
que 80% des enfants attikameks dont
pouvaient maintenant demeurer dans leur
communauté
est ce que l'objectif ultime c'est
d'atteindre 100% possible si c'est
possible d'amener notre réservoir sa
voix toujours c'est ce qu'on va toujours
essayer de viser le top ten est
imposable il rien de parfait si on
compare des tentes ou vous-même pose la
question des limites son pari des
maîtresses page dimensionné tout imputer
aux c'est vraiment un manque de
logements on veut garder les jardins
dans la communauté on veut la garder les
jeunes va enfin dans les familles média
le plus possible non des jeux des
maisons qui tombent du centre et son
peuple et dans des très rares comme un
fou et c'est impossible de donner ses
services parce que je suis justement le
manque de jeu mais enfin ça on était
obligé de sortir enfin et pour que ça
fonctionne il faut aussi même si je peux
connaître un peu la communauté où la
culture je parle pas la langue
j'ai pas grandi dedans et en travail
social il ya très peu d'atika mec a
l'air d'être intéressées d'aller dedans
donc pour ça marche il faut aussi qu'ils
aient ce personnel là qui qu'ils soient
là même si tout le monde peut aller mais
c'est quand même ça qui fait la
différence et ça c'est aussi un gros
défi sa sortie 10 des sujets que vous
êtes tous bien des problèmes soient sous
tout vient du manque de logement tout
devient kannad et des stocks
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en arias qui
passionne
la création des réserves le président
fit et wii son territoire tout sans
enfant soit on est dans une situation
actuellement qu'une situation sociale
vous voyez est comme ça crée des
problèmes nous absenter salle est
consacrée mais également un beau taux de
diplomation donc on n'a pas le bien
qu'ils vont utiliser vraiment au cégep
ou à l'université va chercher des
billets l'association ou un travail
social oui on travaille très fort là
dessus c'est certain qu'on va terminer
avec une question qu'on a reçu
d'ailleurs d'une personne qui nous suit
sur facebook elle s'appelle annie
chevalier juno et elle dit je cherche
une formation autochtone en travail
social à montréal j'en ai vu aucune est
ce que ça existe
voilà j'ai déjà vu quelque chose à
joliette pas tatoué à travers jeudi je
me semble que j'ai déjà vu quelque chose
entre en éducation il y avait déjà eu
quelque chose pour les attikameks ya des
cohortes qui sont organisés en travail
social a également l'éducation cse que
n'approche un peu plus culturellement
adaptés mais il ya encore une carrière à
ce niveau lors il n'y a pas de programme
en tant qu elle qui qui est un travail
social avec approche autochtone mais je
sais que ça va se développer
prochainement sur tout ça des gens qui
nous écoutent ça fait partie des défilés
c'est ça on veut combler ce défi là
comme ça mais comme le dit comme il
l'entend tous mentionnaient pour nous
l'objectif c'est vraiment avoir le plus
le maximum possible c'est déjà indiqué
mais qui vont intervenir dans le système
déjà convaincu pas de moi qui a pas deux
comme tout de suit la langue il est la
culture mais vous refusez pas les autres
on ne refuse pas désolé
actuellement ce que vous avez vu sur le
terrain se sont beaucoup plus des
attikameks qui travaille justement avec
les fans il est vrai mélange et je vois
ça c'est assez mixte et un peu des deux
mais je pense que les personnes
allochtone qui sont là sont là depuis
longtemps et le hamas la culture
aussitôt fait mais lorsque j'ai beaucoup
de pourparlers pour acheter ma main
la sûreté du québec sont recalés alors
ça va être notre mot de la fin donc on
invite les attikameks à se tourner vers
les métiers de travail social pour 2 [ __ ]
les gens de leur dollar comme une
autorisation de bâtir notre dame est à
tout était bon mais oui les premières de
toutes les premières nations en effet
merci beaucoup grands chefs dans ce
temps-là watches de vous êtes déplacé
dans notre studio à montréal pour en
parler
c'est un projet dont vous devez être qui
n'est plus un projet mais qui est
maintenant fonctions dont vous devez
très fier on est très fiers c'est ce qui
ma robe
notre état qu'on aimerait développer oui
on a en quelque sorte une certaine
délégation qu'un qu'on regarde au niveau
je vais certainement à ce niveau pour
nous on va toujours utilisé l'auto
d'état menace et en plus ça nous amènera
à vauré invité pour parler de bien
d'autres dossiers qui concernent des
attikameks entre autres avoir fait leur
merci ni gouache
merci beaucoup isabelle picard à la
semaine prochaine on se retrouve sur ce
plateau
merci et puis merci marie laure n'est
venu nous parler dont de ce dossier que
vous connaissez vraiment très très bien
un an une fois de parler la langue
il ya du travail alors donc un papier
sur espace autochtone long papier avec
les photos qui racontent donc votre
voyage et les clés de la communauté
vêtements et puis un reportage si vous
voulez écouter les gens parce que c'est
eux qui s'expriment le mieux donc dans
un français parfois pendant ma tuque
amex et dimanche à des hôtels dues à des
jeux télé dimanche donc sur la première
chaîne de radio canada
merci à tous les droits et merci à vous
d'avoir été à l'écouté une fois de plus
si vous avez envie de commenter de poser
d'autres questions aller sur notre page
facebook vous allez pouvoir compléter ce
dossier merci beaucoup
à bientôt